[Music]
what's up BuzzFeed oh yeah VIP tables
whose an lol do you have to oMG to get a
seat up in the VIP section a commonly
known as the splash zone fair warning
I'm a squirter myself so the rumors are
true I got a restaurant idea guys for
Lord of the Rings themed restaurant
called Mordor and when you come to this
restaurant the waiters greet you by
saying welcome to Mordor
may I take your order I'm kind of I'm in
kind of a rough space man kind of a
weird weird mood my my grandpa died
recently yeah he was a really
philosophical guy and I was actually in
the room with him when he died and I'll
never forget his last words he said the
black nurse drank my orange juice and
poof it's off to the heavens
always remember to follow your dreams
[Music]
such beautiful last words grandpa he's
alive are you thirsty grandpa a black
nurse drank my orange juice actually I'm
a doctor this isn't about you grandpa
yeah he's dead oh wow my mom tells me my
comedy makes people feel uncomfortable
for the record she also wants told me
that Mount Rushmore occurred naturally
when I was a kid I was diagnosed with an
auditory processing disorder the doctor
explained it to me but I was like what
the hell is he talking about I played
violin when I was a kid one of the
reasons I played a violin was there was
this really cool jockey dude it was like
hey Pat hey Pat you want to get laid got
played violin looking back I'm pretty
sure he said football pretty sure I miss
processed a crucial bit of information
you want to get laid nerd who's asking
I'm asking well then no I'm not a
ballerina if you want to get laid
violin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo Stephanie I play violin now if you
want to get laid play by a bar you wanna
get laid
play football
[Music]
mm you want to get laid
play violin no it was rough you know
playing violin I got called a lot of
names guys names like fiddle [ __ ] and
dick hands some of the names were
unrelated to my violin playing the worst
nickname I had though is a vagina
dehumidifier yeah harsh I mean coming
from your guidance counselor I was
having seven sex
the 35 year old woman she kept calling
me daddy
I was like what does she call guys or
than her
my guess is Brigadier General that's my
guess if I were to take one
oh yeah come on grandpa oh yeah
you mean that wrinkled dick Oh Aaron
ancient fossils tell me about the war
[ __ ] me who has been an old man voice to
me Oh [ __ ] you George Washington oh
you look like Christopher Lloyd Oh take
me back to the future
brake it hit me right here right now
is intense
oh do you want some Fran juice okay what
the [ __ ] is going on here I got some I
got some movie ideas I'd like to pitch
first movie idea it's called speedboat
catastrophe
it's a melodramatic tragedy got a guy
named speedboat battling Crohn's disease
movie idea number two titled horse on
the freeway
everyone in LA is late for work one day
because there's a horse on the freeway
the whole movies just people honking
their horns just scream and like what
the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] are you kidding me
should have never moved here ah and
[Applause]
[Music]
hey are they gonna pepper in more laps
win-win when we edit is there gonna be
more god man
[Applause]
sittin on my bedroom floor feelin so
loud
blackout all the windows and disconnect
the phone no one calls me anyways no one
even cares I could disappear like a
ghost in a graveyard open up the dresser
drawer where I keep my gun the cold
black steel looks up at me like shadows
at the Sun I load it up with bullets and
I down a glass of rum it burns my throat
but that's okay cuz it numbs the pain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
crying like a newborn child my hands
they shake with fear I think it's what I
have to do but I'm not thinking clear I
close my eyes and count to three and
draw one final breath then I put the
hand gun in my mouth and guess what
happens next
I suck the gun like a Jim stop the gun
like a damn stop the gun like a jab
I suck the gun like a day
[Music]
gobble-gobble-gobble-gobble yum yum yum
yum yum
I want this 38 to shoot a load across my
tongue my troubles are forgotten because
I'm having so much fun sucking this gun
like deer alright thank you so much
ladies gentlemen have a good night
[Music]